alors que chaque mairie souhaite avant
tout avoir de la visibilité dans sa
gestion du comider dans l'application
des restrictions le conseil scientifique
national est il dépassé doit-on le
renouveler ou doit-il être décliné dans
chaque ville on en parle tout de suite
dans notre face à face et nous sommes
avec alain houpert radiologue sénateurs
les républicains de la côte d'or avec
mais également par téléphone marguerite
médecins généralistes député la
république en marge de l'aisne messieurs
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors marseille a on
disait va donc se doter de son propre
conseil scientifique avec comme
intention d'être au plus proche de la
situation quotidien et permettent que
des personnalités marseillaise puisse
disputer et faire des propositions
plutôt que de laisser faire l'état alors
à laon père est ce que c'est une bonne
idée
j'ai observé avec attention la
proposition de samia ghali qui était une
de mes collègues puisqu'elle était
sénatrice
je comprends sa démarche ce que le
professeur out qui est un éminent
scientifique a été traîné dans la boue
et conseil scientifique nationale dans
lequel il a finement en déficit décidé
d'abandonner son siège qui était composé
de sept membres qui avait des conflits
d'intérêts avec des laboratoires et je
comprends que c'était lui samia ghali de
marseille sont sa fille sa ville
discriminés par rapport à décision
parisienne et un comité scientifique
parisien particulièrement suspect est
mort relate est ce que vous vous
partagez ce constat qu'on s'identifie qu
un particulièrement suspect pour alain
houpert
est ce que vous comprenez ce soit samia
ghali finalement est bien de fonder son
propre conseil scientifique
écoutez je vous prédis renaud muselier
saint lô
quand cette décision et je pense que le
conseil scientifique n'a pas failli dans
ses missions d'ailleurs début juillet
avait annoncé il est d'ailleurs
une demande express express de sina
quant à prolonger sa mission
il avait déjà non deuxième vague pour
septembre octobre il avait signalé
justement le que le processus se
déroulerait sur les au moins 20 grandes
métropoles françaises et pour une
population plus jeune donc il a loin il
est loin d'être failli dans sa mission
et je pense qu'il est tout à fait
légitime dans sa mission technique quant
à éclairer les décisions politiques
alors on perd ce qu'est ce que vous
répondez est-ce que ce conseil
scientifique
à quel niveau vous vous l'avez vu
faillir
je n'ai jamais fait mystère de ma
proximité de pensée avec didier rahout
la médecine est une science qui est
guidé par un doute permanent et le
conseil scientifique se fait un instant
t parce que l'état des connaissances
permettent d'aboutir à un con c'est qu
un consensus
jusqu'à ce que de nouvelles découvertes
le père le remette en question
donc j'ai vu lors de ce conseil
scientifique opposé des molécules et des
protocoles ajouter des comités au comité
et voir que l'exécutif décide d'une
médecine officielle la parole de
monsieur de l'axé la parole de la pensée
unique
pour moi il faut laisser les médecins
prescrivent je suis partisan d'une
médecine participative active où le
patient est acteur de sa guérison
on n'a pas besoin de match un
administratif de plus mais d'un exécutif
qui fasse confiance au médecin confiance
aux médecins
les deux médecins qui acceptent la
responsabilité d'aider guidant et dix
soignants face à leurs patients la
médecine c'est une relation entre le
patient et le souhait marque de là
qu'est ce que vous répondez à l'envers
si vous dites vous êtes le porte parole
finalement d'une médecine officielle
d'une pensée unique et qu'il faut
laisser le médecin prescrire quelle est
votre réponse
on est droit d'être d'être dans une
pensée unique que le patient soit acteur
de santé et yann et bien évidemment il
faut tendre sur le fait que le patient
soit recteur de santé morphée
quand on voit la composition du comité
scientifique nous avons quand même des
gens de haute compétence et qui ont
justement tout le petit frère de membres
quant à donner des éléments pour que le
politique décide pour moi la
problématique si vous voulez autres
cétacés
c'est toute la problématique de
l'effondrement de la confiance vis-à-vis
des scientifiques pas seulement entre
les politiques publiques mais aussi des
politiciens et du public avec la science
d'autant plus que lorsqu on recommande
effectivement que les conseillers
recommande eu de nouvelles restrictions
aux libertés mais dans un pour le bien
commun et donc si vous voulez il faut
pas avoir peur en fait j'utilise
d'accord c'est ce que disent d'ailleurs
est à noter deux revenants dans un celi
et on est certainement plus dans le
niveau du débat du consensus
après vous savez les désinformations le
comité scientifique il est pas seul il
interagit avec la haute autorité de
santé avec santé publique france et
l'ensemble des comités scientifiques
mondiaux donc arrêtons de faire un
trophée politique à un comité
scientifique qui donne et qui fait son
travail du conte du technique et qui
oriente avec discernement les déficients
des politiques alors sur cette volonté
de créer un vrai conseil scientifique au
niveau local l'objet de notre débat je
vous propose d'écouter ce que disait
hier sur notre antenne fabrice di vizio
il est avocat de soignants en l'écoutons
réagi ensuite il n'y a pas de réalité
des territoires
il ya une réalité que deux réalités
nationales on a un virus qui circulent
soit territoire national alors avec plus
ou moins d'incidents selon les régions
mais je veux dire alors demain matin
est-ce qu'il faut que marseille s'est de
son propre conseil de défense et son
croît pas conseil de sécurité à quand
une police municipale armée est
effectivement un tribunal et une loi
marseillaise vous voulez quoi rétablir
les coutumes le coutumier du mauvais
this fier parce qu'on en est là à un
moment donné c'est à dire
qu'effectivement concrètement il m'avait
semblé que l'état unitaire et que
l'unité de l'état est un progrès dans
l'histoire du droit là tout à coup on
est en train d'effectivement rester veut
restaurer des espèces de coutume locale
avec des conseils locaux
mais tout ça va engendrer une confusion
supplémentaire marc delas de médecins
généralistes débuté la république en
marge de laine vous vous rejoignez ce
constat de fabrice division aujourd'hui
pas de réalité de territoire mais une
réalité nationale
alors qui est une réalité nationale dans
le cadre du de décisions qui touchent
toute la population l'hexagone
de même que les outre-mer est vide a
évidemment mais qu'il fallait aussi
concerté qui est de dispositifs par
exemple de vierzon pour des formes de
participation délibération citoyenne
pour pourquoi pas mais de là à doter
effectivement chaque petit petites
tentes adieux du d'un comité
scientifique très sincèrement alors que
justement le comité scientifique a fait
preuve de son efficacité
ça n'a pas de sens et en plus si vous
voulez ça ça entraîne le virus si vous
voulez circulent nous n'avons
actuellement pas d'outil préventives
comme le vague star on n'a pas un taux
d'immunité collectif suffisant on est à
peine allant de 5% et de ce fait nous
nous sommes pris par le temps et la
réactivité elle passe par des décisions
effectivement plus pire pyramidale si on
peut dire mais qui d'un tir sur
l'égalité de terrain dans la mesure où
des les schémas six volumes ne sont pas
statiques sur les schémas concernant la
limitation des propagations
il faut bien que dans les métropoles
effectivement il ya une concentration de
population bien plus élevé ce qui
explique que cette circulation du virus
et puis il faut il protéger les plus
fragiles sont plus de 22 millions donc
toutes les mesures qui ont été faites en
faveur des pad notamment il ya eu une
saisine du cfm pour aider la souffrance
qui quaife et il est avec nous comment
dit nager avec eux la préconisation de
geste barrière c'est de la faire du bon
sens mais on est dans un processus
dynamique qui nécessite une réactivité
une adaptation en fonction des
territoires
c'est ce que préconise dans les options
que le cas donné le comité scientifique
notamment des options qui repose si vous
voulez sur des paquets de mesures
différencier une route sur dix est sûre
le mesures modérées voire de mesures
fortes en fonction du taux d'incidence
c'est ce qu'a proposé le conseil
scientifique de façon très pragmatique
et à laon père justement ça ça
fonctionne on passe ce selon vous ce
qu'a proposé le conseil scientifique
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
monsieur de le conseil scientifique a
montré son insuffisance et de faire des
conseils scientifiques locaux
quand il ya trois dangers le premier
comme l'a dit renaud muselier ces deux
d'un machin administratives de plus au
delà mais qui va au delà la formule du
général et à force d'éclairer dans tous
les sens on va finir par éblouir et puis
personne ne verra plus rien deuxième
danger celui du clientélisme avec le
risque plus grande une proximité avec
les élus et les laboratoires installés
en région et qui ce qui risque de
multiplier la suspicion est le troisième
danger c'est de s'enterrer carte la
santé c'est un restaurant cpo menu c'est
pas du tout à la carte
alors regardez ce que pense le
professeur arnaud fontanet il est membre
du conseil scientifique kobe 19 et pour
lui il y as peut-être aussi un problème
de personnes regardent et nous avons
déjà travaillé pendant quatre cinq mois
dans des conditions éprouvantes
je suis convaincu qu'il faille de
nouvelles personnes dont le conseil
scientifique parce qu'il faut que des
idées de nouveaux
la rive marc platt c'est une urgence il
faut aujourd'hui des nouvelles personnes
dans ce conseil scientifique vous
rejoignez ses propos de du professeur
fontanet écoutez quoi qu'il en soit
l'idée de nouveau de nouvelles personnes
c'est la s'implique aussi de nouvelles
compétences
après vous savez vous le savez bien nous
sommes dans un air d'une betting
prédictive l'épidémiologie et est une
science qui nécessite d'avoir aussi des
compétences dans le domaine du numérique
donc le le conseil scientifique
d'ailleurs s'est renforcé à ce niveau
puisque vous n'avez pas que des médecins
vous avez des sociologues
vous avez des spécialistes concernant le
numérique dans le l'ensemble des
personnes qui le composent donc ils
n'ont pas attendu si vous voulez de de
renforcer au delà ou là de d'aider les
médecins à yahoo marial est grave qui
est dans le milieu associatif
emery nos angles dans les nouvelles
technologies
voyez dans donc où daniel benamouzig qui
est sociologue
donc on a on a une multiplicité de 2,2
de vision de de richesse au niveau des
compétences alors à la ouvert on voyait
à lever les yeux au ciel quand marc
delas de prononcer les multiples qu'on
fait quand compétences pardon qu'il y a
au sein de ce conseil scientifique
quel est votre avis à ce sujet
compétences vous avais dit le mot
compétences je pense que pour un conseil
scientifique consacrée à une épidémie de
cette ampleur il faut des vrais
compétences et ce sont des scientifiques
des médecins et le conseil scientifique
a vraiment montré son incompétence par
ses conflits d'intérêts sa suggestion
aussi à la halle aux mails ski qui a
fait un pas en avant et deux pas en
arrière
il est vrai qu'on ne sait rien
face à cette épidémie on sait pas grand
chose mais il ya des endroits où ça
marche
les faits sont têtus et on est face à un
gouvernement tqt tuque c'est ça le
problème qui ne reculait devant rien
souvenez-vous du décret d'olivier dire
en interdisant la chloroquine ce décret
est un email maintenant on peut
prescrire la chloroquine mais surtout
pas associé à l'azithromycine et on peut
prescrire un nazi trois piscines surtout
pas associé à la chloroquine donc on
revient on voit bien que ce gouvernement
de congés cacher son incompétence et sa
responsabilité
marc de l'ade ce sera pour vous le mot
de la fin
alors est-ce qu'on renouvelle ou en
décline le conseil scientifique
bah écoute et on leur nouvelle je crois
que sont pas avoir peur du désaccord il
faut savoir aussi que la connaissance du
vélo y sont depuis plusieurs mois nous a
permis de mieux prendre en charge les
malades en réanimation
ce qui fait que en associant notamment
les corticoïdes exams états honnête il
en mieux l'obsession des thérapies nous
sommes beaucoup plus à même de sauver
des vies donc le quand je veux pas
revenir sur le débat de l'exacte loukine
qui n'a jamais montré réellement sa
preuve
et ça c'est un super un faux procès avec
une politique à une politisation
outrancière que je t'aime nancy rennes
et dans un contexte pour demir voyons ce
feuilleton sérieux en tout cas un grand
merci à tous les deux d'avoir joué le
jeu du n'est pas là on perd je rappelle
que vous êtes heures radiologue
sénateurs les républicains de la côte
d'or marc delattre médecins généralistes
député la république en marge de l'aisne
merci à tous les deux